but but you understand what i'm saying
some people are saying that oh no i'm
not in the mood a right man will get you
in the mood yeah i don't know about i've
either been definitely actually yeah
as far as i'm concerned
then women are out there performing like
i say kali longus when they're not
pregnant
and then when there's whatever it is and
whenever they decide that oh yeah i'm
pregnant open your mouth
open your mouth because you was opening
your mouth before opening your mouth
they will give their best to all the men
out there and then when they come home
when they get home later on in like late
in life it's like oh i don't do that you
know you were doing it when you're yeah
we want to we want the free father with
the twist
now that before they even say they're
dropping on their knees as far as i'm
concerned if you can do that when you're
young do it when you're older your knees
still work baby at me well it's almost
like girls don't want to earn a guy
anymore this one's just falling out
there but oh no i'll go ahead you know
what i'll get rid of the headache for
you
i will get rid of that
natural paracetamol
[Music]
you need to go out there and do it
because as far as i'm concerned some of
them women got big mouth stories and
feel it
and they're gonna sit down oh no i don't
do that and then you can hear from jack
and harry down the road oh yeah oh yeah
she gives good heads you know you can do
it give it to your man give it to your
man that's what when the men are talking
about you giving your good years to
somebody else because you go there you
free up for everybody else and then you
want to come back and go like oh no i
don't do that yeah you do
yeah you do you know i don't want to
hear them i got a headache i got a
period i got this i got that what are
the men gonna stop with it how long do
you have a period for 40 years do men
want to part with that for 40 years
no not they don't they don't exactly and
then there's a problem they're always on
their period she's on their period the
week before
what should what should she do what
should he do if she says she got a
stomachache
i was helping a rubber star come on
any headache
any headache the right sex can get rid
women who want to make love they want
the rose petals they want the bubble
bath they want the mask out come on
please the one man's got time for that
no matter what's going in and out you
know i mean before he goes to work if a
man's like you drop me i've got 10
minutes no you've got 10 minutes i've
got yeah i've got 10 minutes for you
because what i'm gonna let you go to
work frustrating i'm gonna give you five
boys listen right i'm gonna empty you
before you leave the house i mean men
need to be emptied before the house fool
their belly empty their sacks
actually such a kind of way i agree with
that i like when are women actually
saying like constantly obviously can
happen some i mean we human being like
we get sick too but like when are we
even actually saying constantly i got a
day canada man forgot about it because
she doesn't want you anymore like me
personally like when i actually end up
actually a very long relationship it was
for that reason like there was no way i
didn't like it anymore like i wasn't in
love anymore so there was
also sex was missing so she actually
right if you actually such a you know
one you want your men
so if women stop having sex with men
you're saying the man should just leave
you because at that point you know it's
done yeah
yeah it can happen once in a while
because you you know there's real reason
like you just had the baby you know
whatever but like when it becomes
something constantly they are gonna say
no no
man just leave yeah
she says no once go somewhere else
i'm not even waiting yeah because
i'm sorry about that i can't take
rejection
you know i mean i ain't rejecting nobody
else so as far as cause if your man's
coming to you and you're his woman
and you're gonna say no leave
don't give a chance to say no to you
again because there's lots of women out
there they're not forgetting how many to
one yeah he doesn't want how many to one
there's there'll be lots of women out
there gonna say yes to you so don't let
a woman come to you no no no i've fallen
out in love with you so then leave us in
leave the relationship leave the
relationship who wants to have a sexist
relationship we leave the relationship
don't you
keep her there and cheat leave that's
the point i'm trying to make auntie i
got a question for you what should a
dude do if his wife gets fat
leave her
no seriously nah nah nah nah nah because
come on
you meet a woman
you me lisa if you can't help her
right and she won't help herself leave
her yeah because that's changing the
contract because you never married her
like that i'm the same size now as i was
36 years ago
and as far as i'm concerned my man
thinks i'm fat now because i put on four
pounds so i've got to lose that four
pounds yeah i mean because i would i was
four pound heavier but as far as i'm
concerned
if the women there and they're eating
they're eating they're eating they're
eating the eating they don't want to
help themselves leave them
why oh if not and you're married keep on
feeding them and just insure her buy all
the fattening foods going just kill her
off and just
die natural causes and claim the money
back
so okay so dude he should leave his wife
if she's not sleeping with him
what else what other reasons what you
think if she can't cook and she can't
clean
up
it's the right a woman needs to do all
of them things before you put a ring in
her finger and if the woman can't cook
take it home to mummy unless your mother
can't cook but no she needs to learn how
to cook i had to clean
and money
she needs to know how to sort out her
finances
not like oh i've got a bill i'm going to
go to daddy they need to sort out there
because too many women
waste money and the women the men let
them waste the money and then they waste
all their money and then they want to go
and spend the men's well yeah women
women own 70 to 80 percent of consumer
debt even though they um they make less
money i bet nine out of 10 women got
clothes in their in their in their
closet that still got tags on yeah yeah
that's right yeah yeah you see men don't
do that
and women buy stuff that's fashionable
every time they want us we knew the
fashion member classic clothes that they
can wear this year next year the year
after but women just we may just waste
money you want a woman that's good with
money good in bed good with children can
cook
was it a chef in the kitchen
a [ __ ] in the bedroom a nanny
and a cleaner that woman's got to be i
think there's about five different
things that you want in one woman guys
how did that how does that sound to you
let's just
get some feedback on what she's saying
no no it sounds good and and like look
to be honest yeah i don't think it's
asking much
you know it's not it's not over and
beyond for those things you know the
basic things like you said cooking
cleaning just to
like and if you've been raised a certain
way you would have been you would have
known that naturally anyway you know
what i mean and then you bring that into
a relationship to be honest the best
sort of raised women no matter what
country they're from are those that are
raised to be
traditional yeah exactly
so when they come into the relationship
oh
can you cook is this a standard tour can
you roll a dumpling can you do fulfill
of course you to take off your
fingernails for do you wear gloves to
season me come on there you go even on
even on the black level even little
things like can you plant do you know
what i mean little things like that it's
like
if they come with no it's like who
raised you type thing so by the time
you've got there you've got two three
four of the things naturally
already